depuis cinq ans il dit ouvre le rideau
de son bar pour accueillir ses clients
ce rituel risque de s'arrêter car elle a
refusé de se faire vacciner contre
locaux vides à part me faire vacciner ou
ne va remplacer je peux plus travailler
j'ai perdu ma liberté
de mon droit au travail à nourrir j'ai
eu la chance d'avoir corrige peut
rouvrir si moi j'ai rien contre les
trois quarts des papes et les vrais
vaccin gêne en rien celui là je les
passerai simon shaw pour l'instant il
n'a pas fait ses preuves donc j'attends
ce que je suis pas normal d'avoir besoin
de l'autorisation d'un président pour
manger une pizza ou aller au resto alors
prise de colère elle a décidé d'afficher
son opposition sur la façade dans la
salle de son établissement vendre ou se
faire vacciner une question difficile
que son fils co gérant estime logique
réclamer un papier pour servir le café
aux gens de devoir contrôler comme ses
co était gendarme comme c'est qu'on
était médecin parce que ça râle de
médical ça c'est pas à nous de le faire
du moins c'est ce qu'on estime c'est
excessif de forcer les gens ce vaccin
pour pouvoir travailler pouvoir manger
ça c'est pas normal ça c'est excessif on
n'a pas envie de se vacciner ce vaccin
pas au bout d'un an on va perdre
l'établissement on pourra plus faire
tout propres et faire tourner à
l'intérieur les clients restent
solidaires avec leur bar favori
je commerçants et en fait on n'oblige
pas avoir passé deux tiers pour tenter
dé passage à la boutique c'est pareil
mais on m'oblige pas à contrôler pas
salutaire alors je vois pas pourquoi en
bar et sera obligé d'en vau dont la dent
donc bon ben ce cas là quoi donc dans le
sénat il n'y a pas de passe à lithaire
quand l'assemblée nationale ait pas de
pass à lithaire pourtant ils sont tous
là il reste là pendant des heures en
revanche les avis sont plus mitigés aux
abords de l'établissement
je suis pour que tout le monde se
vaccinant fait
je comprends que ça doit poser pour
certains des problèmes
d'éthique ou de je ne sais pas quoi mais
si on veut s'en sortir malheureusement
j'ai un peu disproportionné quand même
dit qu à gurs sanitaires on en n'est pas
là quand même en france je trouve
peut-être un petit peu dommage de
éventuellement de père d'un
établissement qui fonctionne très très
bien et qui est très bien gérée
c'est leur état d'esprit maintenant ils
veulent aller au bout leurs convictions
et et chose que je respecte totalement
parce qu'on s'aperçoit quand même que
mal gré mal gré les vaccins qui sont en
place
il ya quand même des gens de malades
avec locaux vides les embauches et les
investissements qu'ils avaient planifié
sont suspendus pour l'heure il espère
tenir six mois et peut être trouver un
repreneur